there's a little bit of a new Vicki this
year oh yeah
we've got new hair weight-loss a new
kitchen which Mary yep and now I change
the last things you know when life gives
you changes change everything so I get
here so that 22 pounds
my face is settled in from my surgery
from three years ago finally so
embarrassing I look like a freak but you
know you got go through that I'm not too
vain where I say you know what yeah I'm
a work in progress
did I think I look better now than I did
before I didn't know I needed it done
but I did I think this is the best in
ten years we've seen you I feel good my
heart's happy 22 pounds that's not a
little bit of weight to lose that's a
lot of weight over a three month period
and I cut out all alcohol 5 sorry Thank
You 500 calories a day Wow and no carbs
so I just did let us in grapefruit in
the morning celery carrots whatever it
could be just very raw and then nothing
really for lunch I would just do water
then water hot lemon water and then I'd
have salad and proteins and it worked
what was the motivation behind that you
just wanted to feel better about
yourself I I was at such a depressed
state that you know I should get older
I'm 54 down your metabolism changes I
put on like 10 pounds from my 40s to my
50s and I never felt strong like I
really I don't want to be a bodybuilder
I don't want to do all that stuff but I
wanted to feel like okay I'm gonna be
single now I got a I gotta look my best
right right
you